that was a veteran heads up play from
Andy Green Stafford quickly into the zone
and that one scored. Oh Pavel Zacha. Looked like he  knocked it out of midair on
from Drew Stafford you see that
fluttering puck in midair and he bats it
upstairs pass Lundqvist as he gets it
behind the range of the defence and ties
this game up real nice goal there
And now Pacioretty with a quick shot
reaching back make that save on his number
Pacioretty loves to shoot this off the
top of the circle look on that delivered
goes up and over the shoulder of
McElhinney just grabs it.
turnover
bad turnover by the Caps
unassisted goal for Hischier as an 18-year old
first overall pick of the new jersey devils. slick finish there
Ward to Boedker but he's stopped by Fleury.
What a save by Fleury his best of the preseason
and this is that athleticism that Fleury
has look at his plays on his left
stretching out to the right and he
absolutely Rob's Mikkel Boedker here's the
blocker save
Bulacan
had Scheifele open. Didn't get enough on the pass.
Here comes Monahan scores!
that's some pretty nifty skill right
there to pick that pass up with the back
skate the back of the toe of the blade
putting up front to himself settles it
on the forehand and then goes past the
glove
lays it ahead in comes Hoffman off back
to Turris
oh what a save by Price. Oh Carey Price!
Breaks out a midseason dandy.
That's the old two-pad stacker.  the left pad and the glove. Must have saw Patrick sitting there.
And now here's Suzuki he has a lane to the net
He has a lane to the net.
off the backhand he scores!
Nick Suzuki and the scoring parade continues for the
Golden Knights great play as Suzuki
picks us up and how about the hands in tight
great little move by Suzuki is going to the backhand
past Demko
Possible two-on-one here as they move up with it
and the centering pass up front Fontaine shot
and Elliott the glove save.
Introduce yourself to Philadelphia Brian Elliott.
the Rangers were looking thinking it
was in Elliot comes up with a great save
and the Rangers are looking the Flyers
are looking the fans were looking
and I'm not sure he knew it was still in his glove.
dropped it.
Anderson is on. Pionk spinning around Nelson
moves to the net and he scores! Rangers win it in overtime
oh wow this kid
played a heck of a game his first game
as a Ranger at Madison Square Garden
finish gorgeous play
laid the puck to the slot Gillies makes
the save rebound
Gillies down the puck's underneath him as
he reaches behind his back
somehow I was able to hang on for a faceoff
what about the presence of Gillies he
caught that in the air with his
the fans are just watching it on the
video try now and they just recognize
that